Sam Brinton
alluded to in my favorite comment of the
day yesterday which I just read
has been fired
he has been fired not
after it came to light that he shows up
to bondage fetish events and leads grown
men around on dog leashes and dresses
them up in weird little leather costumes
not after Sam Brinton shows up to White
House events wearing stiletto heels and
lipstick not after Sam Brent and steals
a woman's jewelry allegedly at an
airport and and clothing and all all of
her possessions in her suitcase
but after he does that
for a second time
and is caught on camera doing it and
becomes too much of a distraction that
even the Biden White House has to fire
him according to the doe Sam Brinton is
no longer a doe employee but the
department of energy cannot comment
further on Personnel matters
okay good not only has the right been
calling attention to this guy and saying
wait what oh you're telling me this
obviously deeply troubled lunatic is in
charge of nuclear waste in the federal
government but even even members of the
lgbtq plus Community have warned about
this guy for a long time
in lgbtq nation not exactly a far-right
publication the headline just came out
is
has Sam brinton's story always been too
good to be true
was Brenton's story contrived or
embellished to manipulate high-profile
leaders and Elevate themselves into oh
that's the
themselves is the singular crazy pronoun
if you don't want to acknowledge that
you're a man or a woman but him himself
is what they mean into the upper
echelons of the lgbtq plus activism and
there he is and what's the story the
story is well Sam Britain's told a few
stories
but the big one
the central part of his personal
narrative his lgbtq journey is that Sam
Brinton was subjected to conversion
therapy
conversion therapy what is it nobody
quite seems to know but if he had the
conversion therapy this was traumatic
and it was awful except his story didn't
quite hold up
he's been telling that since he was at
the treasure Trevor Project the national
Center for lesbian rights now in the
federal government it just doesn't quite
he said that he came out to his parents
at the age of 11 and then his father
started punching him and he went to the
emergency room and then he was sent to
conversion therapy and then they tried
to beat the gay out of him basically but
then his story started to change because
when he was asked about it he said who
was the Doctor Who was the what was the
office what was this
he refused to answer and as lgbtq Nation
even acknowledges
they say this is kind of odd
if such a place existed there's a moral
imperative to rapidly identify the
abusive therapist and contact the
authorities to stop the atrocities
why was Sam Brinton the only of the only
Survivor of conversion therapy I've
encountered since 1998 who refused to
answer such questions
not only had every other Survivor
provided this information willingly but
they were eager to fight back and shut
down their own therapist or ex-gay
Minister and so then Sam starts changing
his story he writes changes the timeline
of when he went to the so-called
conversion there but it's just very
clear to conservatives to liberals to
lgbtq activists it's clear to anyone
who's interested in the truth this guy
has made up his whole story he's
obviously a pathological liar he's a
thief he's a deeply troubled deeply
confused man
and only after everybody in the country
agrees on that from the most super
straight conservative to the most lgbtq
left-wing activist only then does Joe
Biden say okay only after he's accused
of two felonies this is Joe Biden say
okay maybe we got to take him off the
nuclear nuclear waste in the federal
government it's a big part of Sam
brinton's stories about this thing
called conversion therapy
but what is conversion therapy
some people have in their minds that
it's when you you take gay guys and you
they're little kids even they often say
it's done with little kids and you just
basically attach them to electrodes you
just electrocute them until they stop
being gay or something that obviously is
is not the case that is not practiced
anywhere
and that that's that's kind of the image
that the libs wanted to create for Mike
Pence in 2016.
because Mike Pence signed some law that
had some health care provision that
funded some kind of therapy that was
completely misrepresented
to suggest that it was this awful
traumatic conversion therapy
but you know what conversion therapy
actually is
it's when a guy walks into a
psychologist and says hey Doc I'm a
little confused about my sex and my
gender and I'm a man
but maybe I think I'm a woman or I'm a
man but but I'm not really as attracted
to women and I'm more attracted to men
and I don't want to be I want to be
attracted to women and doc I don't know
what to do I don't know how to help
myself work through these these feelings
and the psychological confusion
if the doc tells that guy
that patient
that he is a man say hey buddy I know
you're going through a lot of confusion
but you are a man and So you you're not
really a woman and it is sort of normal
if you're a man to uh have a
relationship with a woman and then maybe
get married or if that is not amenable
to you maybe to remain chased or
celibate if you're experiencing distress
because let's say your religious views
tell you that you can't indulge same-sex
attractions but you have these
attractions so what are you going to do
I'm going to help you work through this
in a way
that is conducive with
your biological sex or understanding of
what sex means and gender expression the
religious views that you hold the
cultural values that we've had for many
many years if if the doctor says any of
those things
that's evil conversion therapy that's
illegal in half the states in this
country
if on the other hand
the psychologist tells the patient oh
hey buddy you're not really a buddy
you're a chick you're a woman you need
to take a bunch of very powerful drugs
you need to head on over to that butcher
down the street and he's going to chop
off your genitals and you're going to
put on high heels and you're gonna put
on a bunch of lipstick and you're going
to pretend to be a woman now if the
psychologist does that that's called
gender affirming treatment that's Health
Care in fact that's pretty much the only
thing the psychologist is allowed to do
in half of the states at plus additional
territories so in more than half of the
country
that's pretty much all the psychologist
is allowed to do isn't that a little bit
weird
in both cases you've got a guy walking
in to a psychologist saying hey I'm
confused I'm suffering from confusion
some distress I'm being torn between two
things obviously he's experiencing that
distress obviously he's not secure in
his views if he were secure in his views
he wouldn't be going to the psychologist
so the psychologist is converting him to
one thing or the other
it's just if the psychologist converts
him to the view that men are men and
ought to behave like men
that's evil that's terrible that's
illegal
if the psychologist converts him to the
view that men can actually become women
and they ought to pretend to be a
caricature of a woman and and undergo
painful mutilations of their body that
is that's the good conversion
does that make sense seems kind of like
the opposite to me why is it the case
that a a man in this country
is not allowed in half the country at
least is not allowed to go into a
psychologist and if he says look I'm
experiencing sexual confusion I think
I'm a woman but I want to recognize that
I'm a man or I'm experiencing sexual
confusion I'm attracted to men but I
want to try to mitigate some of those
impulses and and be able to live a life
that is chaste and does not lead me to
indulge those desires why is a man not
allowed to do that in America
it's not just that the psychologist is
not allowed to practice reasonable
psychology it's that the patient is not
allowed to get that care
which ironically is gender affirm and
care when you tell a man he's a man
that's that's affirming his gender when
you tell a man to behave like a man that
is affirming his gender
and yet today we call up down and left
right and good evil and evil good
there's there's a therapist who I had on
the show years ago years and years ago
because he came out with a book Joseph
Nicolosi Jr
and I've been attacked for even talking
to this guy because it turned out he's a
conversion therapist allegedly he says
that term is ridiculous he refers to his
reintegrative therapy Joseph Nicolosi Jr
uh is just a guy who if you come to him
and you say hey Doc I'm a man but I want
to I want to resolve my confusion seem
more like more like a regular guy he
tries to help you through that he is
persona non grata and he's been blowing
the whistle on Sam Britain for a long
time he said Brinton claims he was in
torture therapy as a young child for
years and can't remember the therapist's
name he later claimed the therapy took
place in his 20s but even as he was
attacking therapies that don't exist he
was engaging in sadomasochism and
simulated bestiality bestiality with
young men and women
of course no one cared about his
credibility until he got caught stealing
the luggage
totally crazy and there are a lot of
swishes and Libs you even identify
themselves on the right who will say
well I oppose conversion therapy what
that doesn't mean anything
conversion therapy it's another example
of the libs
creating a brand manipulating language
to control our minds to control the way
we perceive the world
to to win the debate before the debate
even begins which is the phenomenon that
I described in my book speechless
controlling words controlling rights
number one National bestseller a great
Christmas present still plenty of time
to receive it before Christmas
don't take the there is no such thing as
conversion therapy it's not real lock
that one away with the tooth fairy okay
all there is is therapy there's
psychology
and the kind that is legal today is the
one that tells men fake false things
and the one that's illegal today is the
one that tells man the truth does that
make sense no I don't think so doesn't
make sense at all the rest of the show
continues now you do not want to miss it
if you're not a member click the link in
the description and join us
[Music]
foreign
[Music]